في أوكرانيا ، تعتبر مستشفى وروضة أطفال ودار
للأيتام من بين أحدث
أهداف الهجمات الروسية المميتة ،
حيث يستمر القتال العنيف في
مدينة باكمود الشرقية الرئيسية ، دعنا نحصل على
تحديث من مراسل CNN الدولي الكبير
بن ويدمان أنه سينضم
إلينا مباشرة من منطقة الحرب لذلك  بن كم
هي وحشية هذه الهجمات الروسية الأخيرة
في الشرق
جيدًا ، يبدو أنهم يلتقطون
إيقاعهم في الوقت الحالي ، ضع في
اعتبارك أنه على سبيل المثال ، في بداية
سبتمبر الماضي ، غيّر الذئب الروس
تكتيكاتهم ونحن نركز حقًا
على أوكرانيا.  القدرة على
توليد الطاقة التي توفر
الكهرباء والدفء للسكان
خلال فصول الشتاء الأوكرانية القاسية ولكن
الأوكرانيين لسبب واحد
تحسنت قدراتهم الدفاعية الجوية بشكل كبير وأثبتوا
أيضًا أنهم بارعون جدًا في نوع من
الحلول لأه المواقف التي تم إنشاؤها
عندما تم قصف تلك البنية التحتية ،
يبدو الآن أن الروس يغيرون
تركيزهم بالتركيز على الأهداف العسكرية ، لكن
في هذه العملية ، نرى
المزيد من المدنيين يُقتلون الآن
بالأمس في
مقتل أكثر من 30 شخصًا بجروح
عندما كان هناك  الضربة على تلك المدينة الآن
يحدث أن الضربة
ضربت أيضًا مركز تجنيد عسكري لذا فهم
يركزون بشكل أكبر على
البنية التحتية العسكرية لخطوط الإمداد ولكن في هذه
العملية يُقتل العديد من الأشخاص الآن حتى
المعركة في باهاموت
قائد الأراضي الأوكرانية  يقول القوات
أن تركيزهم في الوقت الحالي هو محاولة
محاولة تدمير أكبر عدد
ممكن من الأعداء بكلماته والاستعداد لمواجهة
أو بالأحرى تهيئة الظروف
لهجوم مضاد أه القتال
مستمر أيضًا في بلدة
من ديفكا الواقعة جنوب باكموت
هناك يقول الأوكرانيون إن
الروس يحاولون محو تلك المدينة من على
وجه الأرض يبدو
تمامًا كما يفعلون.
الأهداف التي أفرغها الروس
كما تعلمون ، توقف الرئيس الأوكراني
زيلينسكي مرة أخرى في
زياراته غير المعلنة عبر أوكرانيا التي
كانت مستمرة في الأيام القليلة الماضية ،
وهذه محاولة منه لرفع الروح المعنوية
بشكل جيد اليوم الذي كان في سومي في شمال
أوكرانيا و  على مدار الأيام السبعة الماضية ،
قام أيضًا بزيارات إلى مناطق
كريسون وخاركيف تلك المناطق أه
كانت حتى وقت قريب جدًا تحت
السيطرة الروسية الآن ضع في اعتبارك أن هذه
الزيارات رفيعة المستوى غير معلنة
تأتي في وقت أصبح فيه المزيد من الدروع
درعًا جديدًا  الدبابات والأسلحة الثقيلة الأخرى
تصل إلى أوكرانيا وبالتأكيد
تتصاعد التوقعات حول
هجوم الربيع الأوكراني المضاد المحتمل وأعتقد أن هذه هي
طريقته لإظهار أنه
يثق أه في المستقبل وما
ستجلبه الأسابيع وربما الأشهر القادمة
الذئب  حسنًا ، لقد بقينا
آمنين هناك ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك ،
دعونا نناقش هذه التطورات الأخيرة
مع المحلل العسكري المتقاعد في سي إن إن العقيد في
القوات الجوية الأمريكية سيدريك لايتون ومساهم سي إن إن
في الشؤون الروسية جيل
دوجيرتي العقيد لايتون 24
الهجوم الروسي خلال اليوم الأخير أو نحو ذلك
وفقًا لتقرير أوكراني ،
تركزت أعنف قتال على طول
الجبهة الشرقية ، ما هي إستراتيجية روسيا في هذه
المرحلة من القتال الذي يستهدف بشكل خاص
المناطق المدنية ، هذه
المجمعات السكنية السكنية ،
ورياض الأطفال ، على سبيل المثال ، حسنًا ، لذا فإن
الفكرة الأساسية وراء
الاستراتيجية الروسية هي تخفيف الأمور.
لاستمرار هجومهم ،
يبدو الآن أن هجومهم قد
توقف في الأساس حول باكموت ولكن
يبدو أن الروس يخبروننا
أنهم يستخدمون بلدات مثل أفديفكا
وفولادار لتحريك
قواتهم إلى الأمام.  ليس
ناجحًا في الوقت الحالي ولكن نظرًا لأنهم
يخففون الأمور في
القطاع المدني كما هو الحال مع دور الأيتام ، فإن
المستشفيات ورياض الأطفال التي
يبحثون عنها في محاولة لتهيئة تلك
الظروف التي يمكنهم فيها
إحضار قواتهم إلى الأراضي التي
تسيطر عليها حاليًا  الأوكرانيون لا
أعتقد أنهم سينجحون ، لكن هذا ما
يحاولون القيام به وجيل كما
لاحظنا أن الضربات الروسية الأخيرة أصابت
روضة أطفال مدرسة ومستشفى
رأينا هذه الوحشية من قبل من قبل
الجيش الروسي بهذه القسوة
يبدو أنه متعمد ولكن ما هو
تحليلك
جيدًا أعتقد أنه من الواضح أن بعضًا منه
متعمد ومن ثم فإن بعضًا منه ببساطة هو
تقنياتهم القتالية غير الكافية
والأسلحة التي تعرف أنها غير دقيقة
أعتقد أنك تعرف أنني رأيت هذا الذئب في
الشيشان حيث كانوا  لقد تم تسويتها بشكل أساسي ،
فأنت تعرف عاصمة روزني
وهذه تقنية
يستخدمونها في سوريا أيضًا ، لذا
فهي ليست مفاجأة ولكن أعتقد أنك تعرف أن
بعض الأشياء المثيرة للاهتمام تتمثل في
إبراز قوتهم في الشرق الأقصى
أنت تعرف أه بعيد جدًا عن
أوكرانيا ، لكنني أعتقد أنه مرتبط جدًا
بتلك المعركة ، نعم ، ملاحقة
الأهداف المدنية في أوكرانيا بشكل واضح
جرائم حرب أه قيد التحقيق
الآن يقول الكولونيل لايتون ،
القائد الأوكراني ، إن أوكرانيا تحاول
إنهاك الجيش الروسي في باهاموت  هذه
مدينة رئيسية في الخطوط الأمامية بالطبع هي
أن الاستراتيجية تعمل بشكل
جيد ويبدو أنها تعمل جزئيًا على الأقل
لأن الكثير من
مرتزقة الروس ومجموعة فاغنر
يقعون في الواقع ضحية لهذا أه
يخسرون الروس يخسرون
القليل جدًا  الرجال أنا في هذه المعركة في الواقع ،
هناك مقابر ضخمة يتم
بناؤها في جنوب روسيا بسبب
هذا ، لذا يبدو الأمر كما لو كان هذا
جزءًا من الإستراتيجية الأوكرانية التي
من المحتمل أن تعمل على الأقل ، لست
متأكدًا من ذلك  هي الإستراتيجية الأكثر فعالية من حيث التكلفة ،
لكنها بالتأكيد شيء
يستخدمونه الآن
ولاحظت جو أنه قبل ساعات قليلة فقط
أطلق أسطول روسي صواريخ على
هدف وهمي قبالة سواحل اليابان ، فما
هي الرسالة التي يرسلها بوتين على ما
أعتقد  هناك زوجان من
إسقاطات القوة رقم واحد يمكننا الذهاب إلى أي مكان يكون
جزءًا منه ، لكنني أعتقد أيضًا أنك
تعلم انظر إلى ما حدث
قبل حوالي أسبوع تقريبًا ، ذهب رئيس وزراء اليابان السيد
كيشيدا إلى أه كييف في
زيارة مفاجئة ودعم قوي جدًا للعرض  بالنسبة
لأوكرانيا ، من الواضح أن الروس
غاضبون جدًا من هذا الأمر وهناك
تعلمون أن هناك تحركًا في الشرق الأقصى
مع أه الأسبوع الماضي كانت هناك
قاذفات استراتيجية استخدموها أه صواريخ كروز
قادمة من غواصة وأشرت إلى أن
سكرتيرة الروسية
قال رئيس مجلس الأمن ، السيد بوتر شيف ، إن الولايات المتحدة
تدفع اليابان إلى العسكرة تمامًا مثل
الحرب العالمية الثانية ، كما يقول بدوره أه
المواطنين اليابانيين إلى الكاميكاز ، لذا فأنت
تعرف المزيد عن الشيء نفسه ، حيث إن
الولايات المتحدة وراء كل شيء تمامًا كما
يقولون إن  الولايات المتحدة هي
محاولة عسكرة أوكرانيا
واستخدامها لمهاجمة روسيا ،
أعتقد حقًا مرة أخرى أنها إشارة إلى أنهم
قلقون من الغضب وأن المعركة لا
تسير على ما يرام ، نعم ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لكم.
أجنبي